CHRIS DIBONA: Hi, everyone.
My name's Chris DiBona.
I look after some space
stuff here at Google--
I mean, I'm sort of, kind of a
relationship guy with Ames.
And we're pleased and honored
today to have Dr. Worden with
us from Ames.
Are you-- what's the title
there, Grand Poobah?
Emperor Liege?
Or what's the title they
have for you at Ames?
S. PETE WORDEN: Unindicted
co-conspirator.
CHRIS DIBONA: Unindicted
Not a bad day in Washington,
yeah.
So Pete leads NASA Ames Center,
our next-door neighbor
and our landlord there
for our space there.
And thank you so much
for coming over--
or having us there but
then coming over
and visiting us today.
Pete has a very long history
both with space and working
for our country and moving
science forward, which is how
I got to meet him in
the first place.
Your career goes back 20
years in the Air Force?
S. PETE WORDEN: 29.
CHRIS DIBONA: 29 years
in the Air Force.
And then short--
S. PETE WORDEN: 29 years,
three weeks, two days.
CHRIS DIBONA: Really?
You can count it off?
S. PETE WORDEN: That's right.
CHRIS DIBONA: And when you were
in the Air Force, you
worked for the Air Force
Space Command.
S. PETE WORDEN: For part
of my assignment, yeah.
CHRIS DIBONA: So I've always
been interested in this about
you, but also about the
relationship between NASA and
the Air Force.
Because there was a lot of
tension at the time around the
Shuttle program, around other
things, wasn't there?
S. PETE WORDEN: Well,
NASA had--
CHRIS DIBONA: This is weird
because you're at NASA.
S. PETE WORDEN: NASA has a
long history, and the Air
Force an even longer history.
In the 1950s, many in the Air
Force began to understand
space was pretty important,
even in the early '50s.
And the ICBM program was--
they probably don't like me
calling it, but they were
space weapons.
And so they developed ICBMs.
And about the same time, the
country got very interested in
space programs in general.
And then 1957, when the Soviets
surprised us with
Sputnik, there was a lot of
turmoil about what we were
going to do.
And there were really
two options.
One was to have the military
run the space program and
expand greatly to do satellites
and so forth.
And then the other one was to
set up a civilian agency.
And there was a lot of turmoil
back and forth.
But President Eisenhower decided
that he wanted to have
the face to the world being
a civil space program.
And it turns out I actually
worked very closely with NASA
in the national security space
program, although it's
important to understand there's
really two national
security space programs.
There's the national security
space program that the Air
Force leads that has things like
the Global Positioning
System and communication
satellites, and then there's
the other program, which I
couldn't even talk about until
about 10 years ago.
But it's the National
Reconnaissance Office, one of
those "no such agency"
organizations that do spy
satellites.
CHRIS DIBONA: The story about
how the world found out about
the NRO was when they were
paying too much taxes on their
Fairfax buildings.
And people are like, well, who
is this actually paying all
these taxes?
Is this the government
paying taxes just so
it can remain secret?
And then they got outed
because of that.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's right.
Well, there was a lot
of different issues.
But we've worked very
closely together
and sometimes competed.
I think probably the really
interesting thing about the
history is that the Apollo
program was really a surrogate
national security effort, that
the Soviets and the United
States sort of mutually decided
to compete in space,
and it was a surrogate
for a hot war.
It was part of the Cold War.
And the issue was that whoever
won that basically scared the
other one, to say that, look,
don't challenge us.
Look what we can do.
And it was a closely
run thing.
But it turned out most
of the people that
started NASA were military.
And we still work very closely
with the military, although
there have been times--
probably the most interesting
one was the Space Shuttle.
When it was developed, the
military decided it didn't
want anything to do with it.
And it turned out one of my
predecessors as the director
of NASA Ames was Hans Mark, and
he was the Secretary of
the Air Force.
And he said, by golly, we're
going to rely on the Space
Shuttle, and so started to
convert the whole military
space program over to use
the Space Shuttle.
And they picked military
astronauts, and there was a
huge launch complex at
Vandenberg Air Force Base that
was for the Blue Shuttles.
And then the--
CHRIS DIBONA: You should
have painted them blue.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well,
actually, we
were going to do that.
CHRIS DIBONA: It
was too heavy.
Was blue the heaviest color?
S. PETE WORDEN: White is
kind of a NASA color.
And blue is--
light blue, sky blue.
But it turned out the Challenger
disaster occurred,
and the Air Force said,
OK, that did it.
We want to use expendable
boosters, which probably was a
good idea not to put everything
in one-- but it's a
long history.
And my boss, the NASA
administrator, Charlie Bolden,
is a Marine general.
Not all of us can be
Air Force people.
CHRIS DIBONA: What rank did you
achieve in the Air Force?
S. PETE WORDEN: I was
a brigadier general.
CHRIS DIBONA: You were a
brigadier general, yeah.
S. PETE WORDEN: Sometimes
called a baby general.
It's one star.
CHRIS DIBONA: A baby general?
Just one star?
Oh, just one star.
Well, come on.
S. PETE WORDEN: I found out
that nobody knows the
difference between a brigadier
general and a lieutenant
general and a major general
and a full general, unless
you're in the military.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah,
I have no clue.
How many-- is that a
star for every--
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah.
Full generals have four stars.
CHRIS DIBONA: And isn't the
president like six stars?
Is that officially what he is?
S. PETE WORDEN: No, he's
just the boss.
CHRIS DIBONA: He's
Well, that's good.
That's really interesting.
I've just always found the
relationship to be an
interesting thing to watch.
So we have questions
from the audience.
But I have many little
questions.
So I'm going to hit a
couple other things.
You and I have been
talking recently
about propulsion methods.
And you had mentioned during
lunch today that you are
looking into a solar
sailer mission.
Do you want to say anything
about that?
S. PETE WORDEN: Sure.
I think maybe if--
take just a minute to say--
CHRIS DIBONA: It's a little
far out there.
S. PETE WORDEN: No, it's
not very far out.
It's pretty cool.
But--
CHRIS DIBONA: I meant
time-wise.
S. PETE WORDEN: I like to think
that NASA does three
things, to kind of give
you an introduction.
The first one, because I'm
a scientist, is science.
And we basically are trying
to find out the
secrets of the universe.
And there's two fundamental
ones.
One is, how did the
universe begin,
and what's its structure.
And the other one is, how
did life begin, and
where else is it.
And what's its future.
And much of what we do is
around those topics.
The second thing
NASA does is--
where a lot of the
controversy is--
our human space program.
But I think we're on the verge
of humanity will expand in the
solar system this century, and
NASA and its partners around
the world are leading the way.
The third one we probably
don't talk enough about.
And it may be the most
important, is to make life
better here on Earth.
And the first A in NASA
is Aeronautics.
And we're going to have
to transition
sometime to green aviation.
One of the big initiatives NASA
has is green aviation.
At Ames, we're doing the next
generation air traffic control
system, so it affects
everybody.
And the other one is really
studying the Earth and
understanding how climate
change affects us.
Most of the data that we base
our climate change models on
is based on NASA data.
But to get to the solar sail
issue is that it's really a
kind of cool concept.
I grew up on "Star Trek" and
"Star Wars." As a military
guy, more "Star Wars,"
I guess.
But I sort of thought we ought
to be building starships.
And in fact, a few years ago,
we started a program between
DARPA and NASA.
But it caused enough controversy
so DARPA and NASA
dropped it.
But now the private sector
is picking it up,
which is really cool.
But the technology is there in
the next 10, 20 years that we
can get access to near
interstellar space.
And one of the cool ways to do
it was actually thought of--
CHRIS DIBONA: You mean
post the heliopause.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah, outside.
So you're really in interstellar
space.
--is, and I have to confess
this wasn't Ames work.
It was actually done at Caltech
and JPL, just to
mention our competitor that we
love dearly, for the record.
Just as you love Microsoft
and Facebook.
CHRIS DIBONA: Love's an
interesting word.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah,
it certainly is.
But it turns out if you're
going to get to near
interstellar space, you have
to get very high speeds.
The highest speed object we have
are the Voyagers, which
are something like 18
kilometers a second.
And the Voyager is like 120
astronomical units, which is
the distance between the
Earth and the sun.
So it's just now getting close
to the boundary between what's
called the heliosphere, which is
where the sun dominates in
interstellar space.
And it took 30 years or so.
CHRIS DIBONA: [INAUDIBLE] how
people treat that, because
we've had like 10, 12
different headlines.
We're exiting the
solar system.
No, we're really doing it.
S. PETE WORDEN: No, we're not.
We're still kind of close.
But we really want to
get a couple hundred
kilometers a second.
And that's possible,
but hard to do.
But there was a concept about 20
years ago that said, let's
use a solar sail, just using
the pressure from photons.
But the problem then is that
the satellites were kind of
big and heavy.
So it was kind of
hard to do it.
But with the development of
these little micro, mini,
nano-satellites, whatever you
want to call them, that weigh
grams, hundreds of grams,
maybe, a solar sail can
actually get you at high speeds
if you go close to the
sun, so like a tenth of the 10
million kilometers from the
sun, for example.
And it's a little toasty, but
machines can handle that.
And you do a couple passes by
that, and you might be able to
get a couple hundred kilometers
a second.
So we're doing a little
bit of a study on
how we could do that.
And we think it could
be fairly cheap.
And there's a couple of
interesting places that you'd
like to get to.
One of them is called the
gravitational lens point.
The sun actually can act as a
lens, so that gravity bends
the light around it.
And that's 600, 800 astronomical
units out.
So if you could kind of align
things right, you could maybe
image planets around a
nearby star or image
the core of the galaxy.
And so it's a really cool
concept, and I think it may be
the next step in
what we can do.
So we're looking at how do you
get these really high speeds.
But it's not too soon to start
thinking about true near
interstellar missions with--
we don't have to have
wormholes or other
exotic physics.
This is--
not that those aren't cool.
But--
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, but that's
not what we're seeing in the
next 15 years.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well,
I don't know.
There's a guy at Johnson Space
Center that's actually working
on warp drives and so on.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, but isn't
that one of those things that
starts with, assuming you have
a wormhole handy, then you
could-- you know, that
kind of thing.
Or you have a negative mass.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, I guess
a lot of people--
NASA sometimes gets criticism
when we work on far out stuff.
But that's our job.
CHRIS DIBONA: It is.
S. PETE WORDEN: It's reasonable
for an agency like
NASA to have a few people
that are really
looking at exotic stuff.
And most of the stuff
is rubbish.
But if somebody doesn't work
on it, you never know--
CHRIS DIBONA: When rubbish
begins and facts--
S. PETE WORDEN: I mean, there's
a guy by the name of
Nikola Tesla that did a lot of
rubbish, but a few other
interesting things like
alternating current and other
ideas everybody thought
was bad.
And so I tend to refer to it
as fruitcake science, but
fruitcakes can be delicious.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, they can
be, especially if you put
enough bourbon in.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's right.
CHRIS DIBONA: Or cognac.
I don't know what you
put in fruitcake.
So near interstellar space is
interesting, but what about
going to see the closest
other solar systems?
If you had to game this, how
would you get there in the
next 30 years?
S. PETE WORDEN: Well,
speed is--
CHRIS DIBONA: It's about
speed, right?
S. PETE WORDEN: It's
all about speed.
And--
CHRIS DIBONA: And then
deceleration.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, initially
you just fly by.
But I think by the end of the
century, we'll be looking at
things even on our
present course.
One of the things I'm kind of
intrigued with, and since I'm
here at Google, you guys got
a lot of money, you say--
that if you have some extra,
we'd be happy to help.
But the--
CHRIS DIBONA: We just bought
[INAUDIBLE] theory, you know.
S. PETE WORDEN: Let the
attorneys note that I wasn't
asking for any money.
But one of the ideas we've got
about speed is supposing we
did a race, a space race that
you set a race track, say 1/10
of an astronomical unit in from
the sun and 1/10 of an
astronomical unit out, and you
had a cup and let the private
sector compete.
Whoever did that the fastest
every three or four
years gets this cup.
I mean, people spend hundreds
of millions on
the America's Cup.
And I think these kind
of things are
going to be a big deal.
And all kidding aside, the
private sector is increasingly
important for our
space effort.
Private sector space endeavors,
whether it's to
make money mining asteroids or
whether it's to do cool things
like get to interstellar space,
or just leave a legacy,
is I think the next step.
And a speed race is kind
of a neat idea that--
so OK, the first winner goes
30 kilometers a second.
And you find after a while,
people are motivated to say, I
want to get up to a couple
thousand kilometers a second.
That starts to give you the
ability to really think about
nearby stars in decades.
Still a ways to go, but at some
point, the nearby stars
are an interesting target.
Probably our first job as NASA
is to figure out what's there.
And the next big thing that
NASA's going to do in science
is to see if we can image
planets like the Earth around
nearby stars.
One of NASA's missions, which
Ames is lead for, is Kepler.
And we're finding that
essentially every star in the
galaxy has planets.
Probably 10%, 20% of them have
planets that are in the
habitable zone.
A lot of those might
be Earth-sized.
So that means a lot of these
nearby stars are likely to
have planets that at least what
we know would be in the
habitable zone about the
size of the Earth.
So our next big step is
how do we image those.
And the technology--
CHRIS DIBONA: And
terraform them.
No, wait.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yes.
Well, actually, I'll tell
you, there is a way--
and I have to-- this
isn't my idea.
You might have heard
of Craig Venter.
He came up with this a few
years ago, said if you
actually wanted to send
something or go to those
places, it wouldn't be Captain
Kirk and the Enterprise, this
sort of 10,000 ton ship.
He said, you might be able
to send a little box.
And the--
CHRIS DIBONA: Put kudzu
in the box.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, it's
better than that.
You actually beam it genetic
information.
It then prints out the genetic--
the correct--
and uses the raw materials
to start life there.
You could print out
humans or---
CHRIS DIBONA: [INAUDIBLE].
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah,
whatever you wanted.
And I suspect that that may be
the way we'll spread to the
nearby stars.
Of course, there might already
be life there that might have
a different point
of view, but--
CHRIS DIBONA: Whatever.
S. PETE WORDEN: The little
box lands, and that's--
if you see a little box out in
the backyard, be suspicious.
CHRIS DIBONA: Go ahead
and step on it.
Along those lines, we've had,
I think, "we" meaning the
world through NASA's efforts,
we've had remarkable success
with the robotic missions.
And I understand that a lot of
that's come out of Ames.
How much would you say that--
I don't want to exaggerate.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well,
it's important to--
most of our science is
our robotic missions.
And Ames certainly has played
a big role in that,
particularly recently.
But there's a lot of other
parts of NASA.
Obviously, the biggest centers
for robotic missions are JPL
and Goddard Space
Flight Center.
We've sort of focused at Ames on
small things, cheap things,
which is good in this
fiscal environment.
CHRIS DIBONA: You had a lot
of missions this year.
I seem to remember you showing
me a poster, and it's like 32,
I want to say.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah, there's
something like 20 to 30
satellites in the next year
that we're launching.
Most of them are little
tiny ones.
But let me talk about
robotics for--
the thing that Ames really
works on is autonomy.
I don't want to use the word
artificial intelligence
because that sort of raises
scary things.
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, people--
that's a loaded term.
S. PETE WORDEN: But autonomy
is something.
So a good bit of the autonomous
work, of how do we
program something to
be autonomous, is
based on Ames's work.
So it may say JPL on the
outside, but it's got some
Ames on the inside.
They might not admit
that, but It does.
CHRIS DIBONA: Southern
California.
S. PETE WORDEN: But this is
a really exciting area.
And you mentioned the work we're
doing with Google on the
Quantum Artificial
Intelligence Lab.
Now I didn't pick the AI part.
CHRIS DIBONA: [INAUDIBLE].
S. PETE WORDEN: But we are
convinced that perhaps the
next step to autonomy is
a quantum computational
capability.
And if I can--
and I'm probably going to get
this goofed up, but the
problem with a conventional
computer is that each time you
add a variable, you double
the size of the computer.
So it's an exponential
function.
So you get above 32,
33 variables, you
can't solve the problem.
In principle, a quantum computer
is linear with the
number of variables and the
number of quantum bits.
So you could have hundreds
of variables.
Now say I want a robot to go
into a cave on Mars and look
for life, which is something
we would want to do.
Inside caves on Mars, which we
know there's quite a few, is a
place that you might have
extant Martian life.
Not likely to be other
than bacteria or
something like it, but--
CHRIS DIBONA: I'll take
what I can get.
S. PETE WORDEN: You
never know.
But you've never been in
a Martian cave before.
And if you have a robot that you
want to send some place--
say if I want a robot
to open that door.
That's 15, 20 variables.
That's pretty straightforward.
But if I want a robot to open
every door at Google, that's
hundreds of variables.
So I can't solve that problem.
CHRIS DIBONA: We call
them Nooglers.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's right.
CHRIS DIBONA: Interns.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's why
you have a card, because
you don't have to--
even a simple robot
can use a card.
But the idea is it's
probably--
a human brain handles thousands
of variables.
We'd like to put some of that
capability in that robot to go
to a place that you wouldn't
send humans.
And potentially, if you can get
a quantum computing device
that will operate at the
temperatures and compactly
enough, that may be the key to
us really exploring places
like Mars, other places
in the solar system.
So we're quite excited about
the autonomy part of it and
that robots are going to
increasingly do more and more.
Now, we still think they're
going to have a lot of
interface with humans.
The robot's going to go hand
in claw with humans when we
expand into the solar system.
But this is really where
I think the future is.
CHRIS DIBONA: Have we ignored
the gas giants too much?
S. PETE WORDEN: That's an
interesting question.
CHRIS DIBONA: You like landing
on things, it seems.
There's not much to land on.
S. PETE WORDEN: No, you can
float around in the
atmosphere, though.
You might have noticed
we had an airship
for a while at Ames.
It's gone now.
It's floating in Jupiter.
But atmospheres are
very interesting.
And there is some tenuous
information that suggests you
could have life in Venusian
atmosphere, for example, and
ideas that you could have
interesting chemistry and life
in perhaps gas giant
atmospheres.
Very speculative, but we've
got to get in there.
And--
CHRIS DIBONA: They're
a little toxic.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well,
yeah, that's so.
But there's not very many place
that aren't toxic, yes.
So the idea of using actually
balloons and airships in some
of these atmospheres is
an interesting one.
And the chemistry is
pretty exciting.
So that's an area that's
a lot of interest in.
But there's so many
cool places in the
solar system to go.
My favorite is Titan.
There's lakes on Titan.
CHRIS DIBONA: Methane
lakes, right?
S. PETE WORDEN: Methane or
ethane, depending on your
preference.
CHRIS DIBONA: I think Pete was
telling me about basically the
concept of water ice being so
hard, so frozen, that it
appears to be the land mass
for the methane lakes.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah, the rocks
on Titan are probably
ice, water ice.
But there's rain that appears.
It's ethane or methane rain.
CHRIS DIBONA: No smoking.
S. PETE WORDEN: What?
S. PETE WORDEN: No.
Well, there's no oxygen,
as far as we know,
so maybe it's fine.
CHRIS DIBONA: You can try.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah.
Although the temperature
is kind of chilly.
But you do have liquids,
and there's complicated
hydrocarbons.
That's one of the more
interesting places in the
solar system to look for life.
And it may be very
strange life.
And to really understand
what's the range.
But there are organisms on Earth
that are methanogenic
that have various interesting
chemistry.
There are strange chemistry
going on on Titan that could
be explained by some
methanogenic life.
So it's a good place to look,
but it's got lakes and
mountains and rain and so on.
So kind of a whole ecosystem.
And in fact, there was a
proposal that NASA I think is
still considering to actually
send a boat to land on one of
these lakes.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, you had
a simulation of sorts
on how to do this.
S. PETE WORDEN: And that's
pretty cool.
Now being an Air Force guy,
that's really a Navy job.
But I think--
CHRIS DIBONA: Mr. Bolden now.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah,
he's a Marine.
It's a Department
of the Navy job.
But the number of places to
look for life, even in the
solar system, we've just
begun to look.
Mars is an obvious choice.
There's clearly water
processes going
underneath the surface.
You actually see with some of
the data we have that in
spring, you see water flowing
out from some of the glaciers.
I've mentioned the Venusian
atmosphere.
In fact, we don't even know if
there's life in the upper
Earth's atmosphere.
It's very hard to sample.
There's a moon of Jupiter,
Europa, that's a giant ocean.
CHRIS DIBONA: That's
my favorite.
That's because I read too
much science fiction.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's right.
Well, there's an ice crust.
You've got to get through
the ice somehow.
CHRIS DIBONA: We have
Minnesotans you can--
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, they were
thinking about putting a
nuclear thing that
melts through.
CHRIS DIBONA: Sure.
S. PETE WORDEN: But
I kind of like--
CHRIS DIBONA: That's completely
reasonable.
S. PETE WORDEN: You have
to remember, I'm an
Air Force guy again.
I like the idea of taking an
asteroid and running it into
it and blowing a hole in it.
And then you can go.
CHRIS DIBONA: And it's
more organic.
It's not really a nuclear
thing at that point.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yes,
it's more sure.
And then the water's right
there, and then--
CHRIS DIBONA: Hey, you might
get a cool splash.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's
right, yes.
But seriously, impacts
are something--
CHRIS DIBONA: We learned a lot
from the Jupiter impacts of
the Shoemaker-Levy.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, and Ames's
mission a few years
ago, the Lunar Crater
Observing and Sensing Satellite.
We ran the upper stage of the
booster into the lunar poles
and were able to prove that
there was large amounts of ice
and other volatiles so that if
you wanted to potentially have
a long term outpost on the moon,
that the resources are
there to support it.
CHRIS DIBONA: As you get further
out from the sun, of
course, solar starts
breaking down.
It's not a great source
of power.
Are we moving back to RTGs?
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, power
obviously in the outer solar
system is an issue.
There's a couple different
approaches to it.
One is that you just make
things very small and
efficient and get them
out there quickly.
And I think the technology using
so-called CubeSats, that
are sort of 10 centimeters on a
side or maybe three of them
together or six of them, is
getting to the point that we
could actually send a mission
and we think use electric
propulsion and get out
to the outer solar
system fairly quickly.
So you've got enough power
without having to use nuclear.
But when you have bigger things,
they only feasible
power source in the outer
solar system is nuclear.
And so it's been
quite an issue.
The standard power sources are
the radioactive decay systems.
They use plutonium.
And in addition to being highly
radioactive, it's just
toxic in its own right.
So it's something that has to be
handled very carefully, and
there's always concerns
about the launch.
But we've developed the
protocols to do that.
But during the Cold War,
we made a lot of--
CHRIS DIBONA: Allowances.
S. PETE WORDEN: No, we made
a lot of nuclear devices.
So one of the side products of
this was a lot of the isotopes
of plutonium we could
use for this.
But one of the unfortunate
things about the end of the
Cold War from some people's
perspective is that we don't
have those byproducts anymore.
So one of the things facing
NASA and the Department of
Energy is to restart the ability
to produce that.
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, it's not
just those, but we've had some
real problems sourcing medical
radioisotopes as well.
S. PETE WORDEN: And I think this
is a broader social and
societal challenge is
that nuclear things
are scary to people.
And that was one
of the bad side
effects of nuclear weapons.
So I think it's clearly
something we have to identify.
One of the ways to get highly
efficient propulsion for
humans is to use a nuclear
thermal rocket, where you use
a reactor to heat a propellant,
and you can get
two or three times the thrust
efficiency that you get out of
a chemical rocket.
Or use a nuclear reactor in
the outer solar system.
We have a lot of electric
power to
use an electric thruster.
So those are challenges.
And right now, they're
pretty expensive.
And it's an area that I think
eventually, we will see
nuclear power being key
to a lot of activities
in the solar system.
But fortunately, as long as
you're in the inner solar
system, the efficiency of a
solar system per unit weight
is actually more than
a nuclear system.
So we think out to
Mars, we can use
solar electric systems.
And in fact, NASA's newest
initiative is going to use
solar electric power
to actually
go move around asteroids.
And I think it's an incredibly
cool thing.
And everybody says, well, why
aren't we going back to the
moon or on to Mars?
Well, we are going to Mars.
But in the meantime, rearranging
the inner solar
system is kind of
a neat thing.
And asteroids are threats.
But solar electric power
seems to be sufficient
to do a lot of that.
So it's kind of a neat area.
CHRIS DIBONA: If you can just
tell me briefly what you think
of the iodine plasma propulsion
systems proposed
out of University of Michigan.
We've talked a bit about it, but
let's talk as if we hadn't
[INAUDIBLE].
S. PETE WORDEN: One of the
important points is how do you
get a CubeSat-- and I'll get
to that in a second--
how do you get a CubeSat out--
we have a lot of CubeSats, these
little things in low
Earth orbit.
And they're doing pretty
neat stuff.
But how do you get them out
in the solar system?
You can use a chemical rocket,
but then the chemical rocket
is a lot bigger than them.
Or you can use electric
propulsion, which is very
efficient, but the trouble
is that it's slow.
So there are some ideas, and
one of the really cool ones
was to use iodine and to heat it
directly using an electric
system in a CubeSat that looks
like we can get a CubeSat
propulsion system that could get
us out even to the outer
parts of the solar system
in short order.
There's a group at the
University of Michigan.
There's a professor,
Ben Longmier,
who's working on that.
And we're pretty excited about
it because it used to take
hundreds of millions or billions
to get anywhere
outside Earth orbit.
But if you could have a CubeSat
that weighs 10 or 15
kilograms and get it to the
outer solar system in a year
or so, the CubeSat may cost $1
million or $2 million, that is
a revolutionary change that
says now the whole solar
system is easily and cheaply
accessible to scientists.
So we're very excited
about it.
It's ready for proof of
concept, we think.
And it really is the key
to interplanetary
CubeSats, we think.
CHRIS DIBONA: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So a long time ago,
Ames worked on something
called the Ames hard suit.
And I thought it was
pretty cool.
I guess it was killed
for various reasons.
Will we ever see anything
like that in the future?
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, one of
the critical issues now is
where do we go with humans.
And Ames is still heavily
involved in human factors, and
we have some work on suits.
Some of those concepts continue
to be developed by
NASA, mostly at the Johnson
Space Center.
And I believe most of the
technology in that one is now
being pursued at the Johnson
Space Center.
However, for the next--
probably until the 2030s, most
of NASA's work in deep space
will be with asteroids, maybe
the moons of Mars.
In which case, the current suits
are probably sufficient.
But I think that these ideas
like that, when we do operate
on a planetary surface in about
15 years, are going to
be critical to it.
So the work continues.
Our folks are involved in it.
But it's not something that is
aggressively being pursued.
AUDIENCE: Most of what you're
doing is more interesting than
99% of TV, except when you
watch it live on NASA TV,
which is as boring
as possible.
So what do you do to make all
the exciting things you're
doing more of a spectator
sport to really
get America's attention?
S. PETE WORDEN: That's
a very good question.
And basically, you folks at
Google do a lot to help us
with that by allowing people to
have virtual presence and
doing things like
Google Hangouts.
That really gives folks the
opportunity to be there and be
involved in it.
In fact, this week, we developed
something called a
space shop, which is kind of a
3D printer, additive, laser
manufacturing thing.
There's a Google Hangout on
Friday, and there's about a
million young people we expect
to-- they're kind of Google
Hangout campers.
And so I think that the
important point is to use this
new technology to let people
ride along with us, things
like Google Glass.
And so it's just making use
of that technology.
Of course, there's always
a lot of controversy.
I learned the hard
way to be careful
about things like Twitter.
Well, I will tell you.
As you can tell, I was
an Air Force officer.
But when we did LCROSS, when
we launched it, I was using
Twitter pretty regularly.
And I had a few thousand
followers.
It was pretty good
for a scientist.
So I went to the final readiness
review, the launch
readiness review at Kennedy
Space Center.
And this was the first time I
got to sit at the adult table,
which there's like 300 or 400
people in the room, and
there's this big wooden table,
and the actual people that
have primary to say, go.
And so they launch
vehicles, go.
Range, go, weather, so
on and so forth.
And the primary payload was
the Goddard Space Flight
Center, go.
And so I had the secondary.
And they said Ames.
And I said, Ames Research Center
is go for the first
precision bombing
run on the moon.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
S. PETE WORDEN: So I got that
reaction, and so I said, well,
that's pretty cool.
I'll put it on Twitter.
That was a big mistake,
really big mistake.
People put two and two
together to get 86.
And they said, you know, he
used to be an Air Force
general and was involved with
some other lunar mission that
had rumors that it
had found aliens.
And some of the astronauts
found aliens or said they
found aliens.
And so they figured out, aha,
this is a secret CIA plot.
There's an alien base on the
moon, and NASA has been
enlisted by the CIA
to bomb it.
And so it was--
and I told the scientists when
they complained, ah, nobody'll
pay any attention to that.
CHRIS DIBONA: Nobody's going
to pay attention to this.
S. PETE WORDEN: Of, course the
next call I got was from the
administrators that several
congressmen are quite upset
and want to have a hearing
about the--
by the way, LCROSS hit within
100 meters of its aim point.
The aliens are gone.
Everything's fine.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
I was going to add, the only
thing missing is the drama.
It would have been worth
taxpayer dollars, in my
opinion, to have sent cameras in
advance to be on the ground
watching you hopefully
hit the ground.
We should double the budget
of any mission to include
multiple HD live streams to
add some drama to it.
S. PETE WORDEN: I love the idea
of doubling our budget.
But it's--
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS DIBONA: TV studios
on the moon.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's right.
I think it's a good point.
We--
CHRIS DIBONA: It's a point.
S. PETE WORDEN: Why don't you
send somebody with Google
Glass there to--
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm curious about what you
think the role of private
versus NASA will be in human
space exploration.
I know companies like
Interplanetary Resources were
founded to send probes to go
out and collect resources.
And it seems like the solar
system is opening up to
private industry.
But do you ever think there'll
be a motive for private
companies to take over the human
exploration part or if
that'll always be
NASA's domain?
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, I'm
interested that here at Google
you ask me that.
On your website about five
years ago, there was an
advertisement for some company
called Virgle that was
recruiting people to
go to settle Mars.
Now it turned out it was April
1, but it had a message from
Larry and Sergey.
It had another one from
Richard Branson.
It was kind of a cool thing.
I'm not sure they were joking,
either, but that's--
but that really leads
to the point.
CHRIS DIBONA: Might have been
a couple of years off.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah,
it might have been.
But that NASA's job is to
develop technology, to be the
explorers and to go out and
find out what's there.
But I think actually, if we're
talking about people
eventually living and settling
on Mars and other places,
that's almost undoubtedly
going to
be the private sector.
And the cost of doing that
is beginning to go down.
In fact, just yesterday, there
was a team meeting at Ames.
There's a private endeavor
called Inspiration Mars, which
is Dennis Tito, who is himself
fairly wealthy, has set up
this program to send two
people to fly by Mars.
About every 13, 15 years,
there's an alignment of the
planets that you can do what's
called a free return
trajectory.
So you can send a capsule,
and it doesn't need any
propulsion.
It'll kind of boomerang
back to the Earth.
And in 2018 is the next one.
And so he's trying to do that.
NASA is working with
them to help them.
They have agreements
with three or
four of the NASA centers.
And I think there's a good
chance that they'll do that.
Now, they're not landing
on Mars.
But the era when the private
sector can begin to do these
kinds of things is upon us,
and they are doing it.
Their view is they want to send
one male, one female,
maybe a husband and wife,
to fly by Mars.
I'll probably get in trouble for
this, but I have to tell a
little story my wife
said on that.
She says, oh, I can
see it now.
They're gone 501 days, which
is how long it takes.
They'll open the capsule.
The wife will get out, dazed and
confused, and not remember
anything, and the husband will
be dead by mysterious
circumstances.
But--
CHRIS DIBONA: Martians.
S. PETE WORDEN: But seriously, I
think that we're seeing more
and more interest in
the private sector.
The private sector can go to
the space station now.
You can get a ticket.
There are people talking about
flybys around the moon.
So I think a lot of folks in
this room will have an
opportunity in your lifetime
to consider private
expeditions, maybe even
settlement to missions to
places like Mars and lunar
poles and maybe other--
asteroids.
AUDIENCE: Before we can go out
into the solar system or even
extra-solar, we still have to
get out of this blasted
gravity well.
And over the years, we've heard
a variety of different
techniques, some alternative
techniques.
And I was just curious to get
your opinion or NASA's
opinions, if those are any
different, on things like the
railgun for inanimate stuff,
space tethers for elevators
for animate stuff, and of the
Skylon engine, a fairly recent
suggestion, a version of things
that have been tried
before, but that idea that a
space plane can actually take
off and land like normal
but get us into orbit.
Are any of these viable?
S. PETE WORDEN: I think a lot
of these ideas are viable.
A lot of it had to wait for
technology to catch up.
I personally, in my career, was
involved in the DCX Delta
Clipper program, which the idea
was to build a single
stage to orbit.
It probably was premature.
But I now see that SpaceX is
actually doing it, although so
far they've just duplicated
what we did 20 years ago.
I want to add that 20th
anniversary of that flight is
next month.
So things like the Skylon engine
is an area that NASA's
discussed with--
there's a British company doing
that, very exciting.
So some of these technologies
look really interesting.
One that we're working at Ames
is microwave thermal rockets
that, rather than carrying both
an oxidizer and a fuel,
you just carry a propellant.
You beam the energy,
using microwaves.
That heats the propellant, and
it gives you, say, three times
the efficiency of a conventional
rocket engine.
We have some funding from the
Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency.
We're going to be testing that
here in the next year.
We're testing it in the US.
Well, we've tested it
indoors here, but it
doesn't go very far--
fortunately.
But we'll be testing that in
Southern California and
eventually in New Mexico, with
the Air Force support.
So a lot of these things
look very promising.
Transportation is hard.
And the other side of this is,
can we just do conventional
rockets more efficiently?
And we're seeing the private
sector make great progress in
that, and not just
one company.
Everybody talks about SpaceX,
which is a spectacular
success, but there are others
doing the same thing.
So I think the same time we're
trying to make conventional
propulsion cheaper, some of
these other things that are
coming along--
so the next 20 years are going
to be very exciting in
propulsion.
I think you'll see some
real breakthroughs.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So Dr. Worden, you talked about
making a space race for
speed to get people excited
about space.
And I was wondering how you
balance this kind of
competition to get people
excited with collaboration, in
that there's a lot of
redundancies in technology
being developed by various
private sector and government.
And I know, Mr. DiBona, you're
very involved with open
source, so I was wondering if
I could get your take on the
balance between collaboration
and competition.
S. PETE WORDEN: Why don't I let
Chris answer that first?
CHRIS DIBONA: So one of the
things that I've tried to
encourage when I've had the
chance, with the federal
government here in the United
States as well as foreign
governments, is that when they
approach contracting
procurement, that they ensure
that knowledge is shared.
Now the Defense Department has
had some good luck with this,
especially around stealth and
the rest, basically forcing
Northrop and Lockheed to give
each other each other's
secrets, as it were.
But we seem to have moved away
from that in a way, which has
been too bad.
I would really value your
thoughts on that.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, NASA and
its predecessor agency, the
National Advisory Committee on
Aeronautics, were really based
on free and open exchange of
information and publishing.
I think an unfortunate trend
has been to put a lot of
restrictions.
And some of them
are legitimate.
There's legitimate concerns
about sensitive technologies.
But I'm always a great advocate
of openness, openness
in information.
So you want to let people that
want to do cool things have
access to all the information,
as much as you can.
I think that--
I spent much of my career as a
Cold Warrior on the US side.
And I think the reason the US
prevailed in that was because
we had an open society with open
exchange of information.
So that it makes possible
the collaboration.
And I think internationally,
that's even more so.
On the other hand, people are
motivated by competition.
So when you go see a sports
game, nobody's very interested
in both sides helping to get the
football in the end zone.
Oh no, you run it in.
No, please.
The score is 8,000.
So I think that we're
humans, and there's
a competitive spirit.
So the key is balancing
these two things.
And capitalism is a pretty good
system to do that, as
long as it's not
unconstrained.
And I think that it's NASA's job
as a government agency to
make sure the information is
there for everybody to use,
but within our own efforts, to
kind of make sure that the
competition doesn't become
destructive.
I mean, there's always--
one of the big challenges of
NASA is that we compete for
especially smaller
science missions.
There's an announcement of
opportunity, and OK, we want
to mention to study
astrophysics, and people compete.
And NASA centers are
parts of that.
I mentioned JPL and Goddard
and other places.
We compete with them.
Sometimes we team with them.
But I think that's good, as long
as the competition is for
a specific item, and it's not
sort of like I'm going to
compete to the death
with those folks.
And we have a big challenge now
within NASA is, what part
of our capability we preserve
for competition that might
actually be duplicative
across centers?
So I think there's a balance
there, and we do
pretty well at it.
But I think in a societal sense,
I'm really with the
idea of open source,
open information.
Everybody should have access
to the same information so
that they can compete
effectively
against each other.
And a good competitor is
one that you want to
team with next time.
I always find that if we're in a
competition at Ames, and one
of the other centers is on the
winning team, and I'm on the
losing team, I'm the first one
to want to go down there and
say to the director there,
can I buy you a drink?
Maybe we can work with
you next time.
CHRIS DIBONA: Maybe you need
some help over there.
I'd love to hear your thoughts
on where NASA is going with
heavy boost, large launchers.
S. PETE WORDEN: I think there's
really the question,
and this is one we don't
have a good answer for.
Is it better to have--
well, if you want to send a
human expedition to Mars,
that's going to be something.
CHRIS DIBONA: Say you want
to send a human to Mars.
S. PETE WORDEN: That's to land
on Mars and come back.
That's an important point.
That--
CHRIS DIBONA: 30,000 people
volunteering to go one-way.
S. PETE WORDEN: People are going
to go one-way to Mars to
settle it at some point.
But you need something that's
big, probably like at least
the size of the International
Space Station.
So is it more cost effective to
launch a lot of things and
put it together in space or to
have a single big booster?
Historically, it's the bigger
booster is cheaper.
So if I have a booster that's
twice as big, the per-kilogram
cost is lower than using
smaller ones.
We don't know if that's always
going to stay that way.
So what NASA's doing in our
internal efforts is we have
the space launch system.
We are aiming at something
eventually over 100 tons.
In fact, Congress says they
want 120 metric tons.
Our first versions will
have less than that.
So we're doing that.
The private sector is
also looking at
larger and larger systems.
SpaceX has the Falcon
Heavy, which I
think is 60 or 70 tons.
They also have something
that I think is called
the BFR, the Big--
I was told that stands
for Big Falcon--
CHRIS DIBONA: Fantastic--
S. PETE WORDEN: --Rocket.
Big Falcon Rocket.
So that remains to be seen.
At the same time, there may be
ideas that if you build a lot
of them, small ones will
be more efficient.
So I don't have the answer.
But right now, I'd probably
bet on the BFR.
AUDIENCE: Could you walk
us through the day
of a NASA Ames director?
How do you divide your time, and
what are you most excited
or worried about?
CHRIS DIBONA: Do you like
bacon for breakfast?
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, I live on
Moffett Field, so I get an
extra 45 minutes sleep over
everybody else, so that's
always good.
But NASA has 10 centers, and
our headquarters is in
Washington, DC, which
is where I want it.
That's one of the coolest things
about Ames is we're the
farthest away from
the headquarters.
CHRIS DIBONA: Visit the
dish and [INAUDIBLE].
S. PETE WORDEN: But that means
that they are at work at 5:00
AM my time.
And so usually the first
hour or two is spent in
interactions with headquarters,
discussions with
one of the leaders about
why did you do that.
But seriously, we're
a big agency.
We have to deal a lot with--
I sort of mentioned, we have 550
board members or so, the
members of the House
and Senate.
So there's a lot of interactions
that one does
there and answering questions.
And I know it's hard for anybody
to understand this,
but they don't all
agree sometimes.
And it's sort of very strange.
But I mean, there's a lot
of interactions there.
Frankly, I have 2,500 people
working for me, and they're
all very creative, so that
means sometimes there are
issues that need to
be worked with.
And I tell people I have 2,500
children, and I'm one of them.
So it's--
trying to figure out
how we maximize the
opportunities there.
But I usually spend a few hours
a day just interacting
with the really cool stuff
that's going on.
Tomorrow, for example, all day
long is the mission readiness
review for LADEE, which is our
next lunar mission, launched
on September 6.
And so that's a really
fun day.
Now, it's fun unless somebody
says, excuse me, there's a
major problem in the
propulsion system.
And then you kind of, oh, my
god, what do we do with that.
So we spend a fair bit
of time with that.
The other thing is, particularly
this time of
year, we have 800, 900
students at Ames.
We have a bunch of
folks right here.
And I really enjoy interacting
with the
students, and I think it's--
so we try to spend a
fair bit of time.
I spend a lot of time discussing
people's future,
discussing what's my
favorite wine.
But--
CHRIS DIBONA: What is
your favorite wine?
S. PETE WORDEN: Whatever
somebody else is buying.
But every day is different.
But I gotta tell you, working
for NASA, and I hope this is
true for everybody, is you
really want to get up in the
morning and go in and work
because it's fun.
We're doing cool stuff.
I used to spend a lot
of time on airlines.
And--
CHRIS DIBONA: Aeronautics.
S. PETE WORDEN: Yeah,
that's right.
Well, one of the advantages.
one of the actual positive
things about sequestration, is
that we've really cut travel.
And we've started to use a lot
more virtual presence.
For example, this morning, this
week, the week of the
20th of July is a significant
date for
NASA, the Apollo landing.
And so we always have the
Lunar Science Forum.
And so we'd typically have 500,
600, 700 people at Ames.
And this year, we decided
to save money.
We're going to do
it virtually.
So I spent the first hour
this morning on the
virtual global meetings.
First time we've done that.
And so that's kind of the wave
of the future, again.
You mentioned, how
do you do things.
So every day is different.
CHRIS DIBONA: Sort of like
turning your own in-person
manned flight into a
robotic mission.
S. PETE WORDEN: Exactly.
CHRIS DIBONA: Where
you just send a
little box with packets.
S. PETE WORDEN: It's
important, though.
Of course, you have to remember
that you're actually
here, being broadcast.
Because there were a couple
incidents where we had NASA
employees that were
in their kitchens.
CHRIS DIBONA: As long as they're
in their kitchens and
not their bathrooms.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, you could
sometimes hear whoosh in
the background.
So there are downsides to
virtual presence, too.
AUDIENCE: Where do you see
Silicon Valley and NASA Ames
with the privatization
of space?
S. PETE WORDEN: Well, it's clear
to me that privatization
of space is happening, as I
mentioned earlier, and that
Silicon Valley is
powering that.
I'm really proud that NASA has
a center in Silicon Valley,
and I think it's really
leading a lot of that.
It's not the only place, but I
can't imagine a more exciting
place to be in the world than
Silicon Valley for anything.
And space is no different
from that.
The sort of spirit of
entrepreneurship, you feel it
here at Google.
You feel it any place in the
valley or in San Francisco.
And it's going to get
us to the stars.
And it really is that
public-private partnership.
We're really proud of working
with not just Google but our
other partners here
in Silicon Valley.
And this is the future.
You never know--
what was it Yogi Berra says, the
thing about the future is
you never know about
it or something?
And it's where things
are going to go.
But we're seeing a lot of the
private sector space efforts
really have their origin
here in Silicon Valley.
Elon Musk was a Silicon Valley
entrepreneur, and a lot of the
other companies, I know of at
least a dozen space startups
here that are doing really well
and privatizing things.
So I think there'll be
a Silicon Valley
on Mars soon someday.
That'll be where they'll build
the interstellar starship.
CHRIS DIBONA: Thanks a lot for
coming over and being here.
S. PETE WORDEN: Well thank you.
[APPLAUSE]